hi everyone this is Evan to Shack and
it's my first video blog
I'm gonna have to learn how to not look
at myself in the picture so much I'm
just drawn to my face I'm a writer
much like John green of the vlogbrothers
I am a nerdfighter too unlike John Green
however I'm not published I did it again
I just looked at myself in the picture I
can't help it do I move my face down to
the very very corner of the screen I
promise I will try not to look at it one
more time for the rest of this video
I've know I've been told by people that
I do that when I talk to them on skype
or any other kind of video chat I'm
trying to figure out what I should do
for my first vlog I have been thinking
about a lot of ideas figured a good idea
might be to start with telling you a
little about myself about what I do and
the reason that I wanted to start a blog
in the first place well my name is Evan
Pugh sheykh that's who then shag um yeah
my childhood was tough living in Los
Angeles like I said I'm a writer I write
novels
I studied filmmaking in Boston for for
many many years now I don't do that
anymore
couple reasons I'm not still in the
filmmaking industry I still love the art
of filmmaking a lot of my friends still
do it and I encourage them to be the
best that they can at it and I still
love talking about it wasn't so much
that I didn't like the business side of
the industry let people say are we gonna
be a bitch for this many years getting
coffee and so on so forth
you know that's tough but I didn't
really mind that so much what I minded
was that filmmaking is an art form that
it's enmeshed in money and you can't
unmess it is unless your word I don't
think so
what it means is this is if you're
really fast you can maybe maybe make
four short films a year and I'm talking
about conception from the from the
writing process on to the final edit you
may be due for a year so if you're
familiar you sort of know that when you
have an idea for a project it's like a
vision inside of your head it might be
triggered by a song or a story or by
something that you see but it triggers
in your head like a vision like a dream
and then the process of filmmaking from
writing to casting to filming to editing
it's all sort of a process of the
degradation of that first idea now a lot
of people like that like people would
say that it's sort of like maturation of
an idea that happens in your head to
something that is definitely going to be
different but could could will be better
also a lot of people like the idea of
working together with a lot of people to
make a project you know because
cooperation is the thing that they get
into it for now I like cooperation don't
get me wrong in my life with my friends
with my family with the people
that I love I am willing to cooperate
with them on act of living on the
process of living I want you to help me
and I'm going to help you and we're
going to get along together the best we
can we're going to be the best people
that we can but when it comes to my art
it's a whole different story
I confess to being a fascist now granted
I think that filmmaking does require a
dictator a benevolent dictator and I try
to be a benevolent dictator it just
still wasn't at the level of control
that I needed for art I'm saying all
this at the risk of sounding pretentious
but I think that that risk is worth
taking and I also think that pretentious
a pretty ugly word when is that I had a
sort of falling-out with filmmaking I
left that and over the process of a few
months I started reevaluate what I
wanted I realized that I did want to be
an artist that they want to create but
what's there a different art form that
would maybe suit me better so I tried
writing first I tried you know writing a
short story then I tried writing a
novella finally I tried writing a novel
just to see if I had the stamina to put
that many words to paper and that I did
have the stamina and that I loved it and
also that it gave me the opportunity to
coddle my work in the way that I want to
you can sort of cuddle a sentence or
paragraph in the in a way that you can't
with a film shot for example so there we
are so I went to Paris for the summer I
wrote my first novel I'm revising it now
and we get to the reason why I am
started this blog partly because I miss
video editing but mostly because I see
blogging as a good platform you get my
word out there someone expressed to me
it was actually a distant cousin who was
a writer he wrote an email to me and he
said you know the dilemma is being
famous before you're famous I thought
that was a really good way of putting it
you know I saw John Green and Hank green
I started to watch the vlog where those
videos and I was inspired by them but
mostly I was inspired by the community
of nerdfighteria I just had this feeling
that maybe a lot of you have too that
you know the future of art and
expression is going to be within these
communities that are built online and
elsewhere where people from all over the
world can get together and share what
they did and I started thinking I'm
willing to support anybody in
nerdfighteria who's got something to
show some form of expression whether
whether it's art or science any of these
things as long as there's some merit to
it and you know merit comes from
practice and practice and practice it's
not everything is good not everybody's
gonna be good
for the people who are and they're part
of my community I'm gonna support you
because that's what a community is now
I'm hoping this may be taken I got a
little bit of a provides
you know I don't know how this
publishing thing is going to work I'm
going into the breach when I'm done
revising this book and I hope that
something can come of it I hope that
it's a good book I guess you'll tell me
that you'll be the judge of that but
thank you for watching my video thank
you John Green Hank rain and all her
fight area for being part of this that
was first guy looked at myself